[Music]
for Ukraine and for the West the
precious building this is now the
comeback expect news of the ukrainians
conducting a host of attacks
as Ukraine's long-awaited
counter-offensive appears to have
finally begun
Ukraine want to achieve
economists Russia and Eastern Europe
editor Arcadia ostrovsky gives his three
key takeaways
[Music]
he has spoken that the full territorial
Integrity of Ukraine needs to be
restored that does mean moving all the
way to the borders of 1991. in practice
uh I think there is a realization that
Ukrainian Army can possibly take quite a
lot of territory to at the very least to
break the land bridge that connects
azolfin and the Black Sea and possibly
get to the borders of Crimea one of the
key things of course is for Ukraine to
be able to liberate and hold that
territory preventing any counter
offensive from Russia
count offensive is not just a single
military event that consists of a lot of
elements including a psychological uh
information uh Warfare so there will be
a lot of deception they will want to
keep the element of surprise when it
comes to the actual military action
Ukraine has been talking about its
counter-offensive keeping Russia in
suspense
the idea is to shatter the picture that
Vladimir Putin is trying to project that
everything is going according to plan
that there is a plan you have to destroy
that picture of normality you have to
sow the doubt in the minds of the
Russian soldiers and officers why are
they sitting in the stretches do they
want to die here and now in the war the
aims of which have never been really
formulated and the longer Ukraine has
talked the greater this psychological
offensive this is mounted the softer I
think the Russian lines are going to be
and we're already seeing it
thank you
president zielinski who's been
absolutely essential for Ukraine's
ability to sustain this war and for the
support of the Western countries this
man who is a former comedian whose
rating was below 30 percent before the
war started has become a symbol of the
nation at the same time to keep the
morale high he has built up expectations
of Ukrainian Victory some would say that
they're somewhat inflated what happens
next uh will be partly defined by the
action on the battlefield it will partly
be defined in terms of security
guarantees bridging this period this
very dangerous period between now and
the time when Ukraine might join NATO
anything that is a gray Zone as one
American Diplomat has said is seen as a
green light by Vladimir Putin and
securing Ukraine in this interim period
between the end of hostilities whenever
that comes and the time when Ukraine can
be a member of NATO which is as much in
the interests of NATO now as it is in
the interests of Ukraine that will be
crucial
thank you for watching and if you'd like
to read more of our coverage on Ukraine
and the war please click on the link
[Music]
foreign